one of the last remaining forests
overlooking the greek capital
kasiriyani towers hundreds of meters
above athens and is home to about three
million trees
and preventing them from going up in
flames is the number one priority for
firefighters
that's why the area is patrolled 24
hours a day during the wildfire season
eugenia raimondo is one of those keeping
watch here she's a seasonal firefighter
during the rest of the year she teaches
high school with each passing year her
summer job is proving more of a
challenge
this year is more difficult than
last year because of the
temperatures and the winds
it's difficult to stop the fire
that's why prevention is so important
and it's all hands on deck here
we are having a double schedule we are
here protecting the forest with our cars
around here also we are watching around
the other mountains per daily parnita
we can see some smoke somewhere and we
have to inform our center
communication center for the
other
cars around the other mountains
we are you know all the time
standby
the government has already spent more
than 100 million dollars on prevention
strategies along with training
volunteers there are 600 of them now in
athens alone
clearing and maintenance of forest is
another way to prevent blazes but it's
not just up to fire crews to keep the
flames at bay
one veteran firefighter says residents
should be helping
when the temperature is high
and the humidity is low
that helps the fire to grow up and to
move
very fast
people and the cities have to understand
that
in such days when conditions and the
temperature is very high
as i said humidity is very low
they can stand for they cannot start for
example a bbq
no
or they cannot make works with
with tools that
can cause a fire
with the current threat level at its
second highest tier people are
prohibited from venturing into forests
a warning these firefighters are hoping
residents will heed
this is the largest and oldest fire
station in athens home to 120 permanent
crew members and 60 volunteers they're
all well aware of the risks they take
fighting the wildfires are greater every
year but they're determined to keep the
flames as far away from the capital for
as long as possible
al jazeera athens